bonjour à tous et à toutes
je fais je vais parler d'une expérience
personnelle mais à propos d'un livre qui
a changé ma vie et je vais vous
expliquer faut voir
je vais parler aussi sur ce pouvoir
transformateur de la littérature
bon qu'elle a ses livres quoi ces
livreurs s'appellera live hilaire vivre
et pull et par l'écrivain radama saab
qui l'a d'origine libanaise mais les
brésiliens et c'est vrai a été pris en
1975 alors ça fait longtemps espace
bon nous amuser la couverture du livre
mais aussi des photos déjà des relations
et maintenant à propos de mon expérience
ça c'est très étrange parce que j'ai vu
pour la première fois c'est les creux
alors j'étais 16 ans et je vais vous
raconter nous profiter parce que
tram en ville chaque école sainte
catherine il y avait une bibliothèque
municipale il est a perdu seulement des
mauvais deux livres par mois mais moi
même je voudrais livre plus des livres
et dans que j'ai volé les élèves
évidemment qui après oui il était
retourné à la bibliothèque et 7,1 dans
cette partie dans ces moments de ma vie
j'étais adolescente s'est enquis et j'ai
lu ce livre pour la première fois et
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai eu déjà six
boucles alors parce que je préfère les
livres et maintenant j'ai harmonies
vocales
qui s'est passé pendant toutes ces
périodes là maintenant j'ai 37 ans alors
le dévent temps
j'ai eu des perceptions
encore prétentions des sensations
différentes
et pour chaque fois que j'ai lisa ses
livres eux c'est comme si moi ma mère
j'ai pas changé
mais je vais pas les questions qui a
changé de l'iphone ou moi
est ce qu'il avoue l'été révèlent peu
changé avec toujours la même
et jamais posé souvent cette question
alors j'ai mis ici parmi vous pouvez
regarder les femmes les plus pertinents
les plus importants en moi
j'ai toujours
les bars les dames ou d'appartenance
être étranger être étranger et ses
demandes sont très similaires la racine
même
je suis étranger suis étrangère ou
étrangers comme là bas qu'est ce qui
fait leur part pour appartenir dans nos
sociétés que c'est appartenir à un
groupe de personnes appartenant aux
familles appartenir mes records de
cormicy mons par
lots si
vous êtes qui m'attire l'attention ce
sont les personnages ce sont des
personnages comme moi comme nous comme
vous personnage de sang facile peut-être
personnage
réalimenter et l'église 2011 identité
mais c'est pendant qu'ils
n'appartiennent pas aux cons lieu en
espaces
et ça j'ai posé la question qui suis-je
un peu pareil comment
le léman qui sentit l'intérieur
qui suis je quel est mon identité est-ce
que je vais partir d'un espace par la
famille mes amis
et sa façon l'état mais le plus
pertinent pour moi et vous parler un peu
du livre il a partagé en deux parties
ce titre qui sera justement la partie et
les taux nous avons ce personnage
principal est la partie intrigue mines
par des familiers super hyper
fonctionnel et s'appelle une anglaise
andrier entre en scène
i la partie de sa maison et la partie
pour s'est trouvée pour
vérifier qu est-ce que c'est par cet été
lors
dé son centre de son oncle de famille
mais un jour il a retourné et ça c'est
très intéressant parce que quand il
avait tourné à sa maison chez lui et l'a
totalement différente et de la poule 2
le même personnage qui avait sorti et a
sorti
parce que c'est transformer et 7 ans moi
j'ai les six partis chez mes parents et
mes parents quand j'avais 20 ans et
chaque fois que j'y retourne je suis
laissé sur votre personne je ne sais
plus le rallye qui j'ai fait avant et ça
c'est un dialogue super intéressant
parce que comme j'aime ici
identification j'ai mis donc je fis
beaucoup avec landry et avec l'exemple
familial auquel
il appartient
une autre chose qui m'a dit vous
conscient nouveau nés ces livres c'est
la mélodie de narrative
à mon avis c'est comme si au moment de
la lecture c'est comme si je veux
t'amuser et cette musique
elle est
indécent de
lente parfois mais parfois l adieu
rythme et ça c'est très intéressant si
alors les premiers chapitres qui
s'appelle la partie c'est justement ça
il parle des souvenirs sur la mémoire
cette danse qui gêne il abat bercer
c'est comme si nous étions versée vous
comprenez oui
après je vais relire vos morceaux des
ces chapitres pas ce qui est
extraordinaire
mais sont intéressantes si c'est que
pendant le premier chapitre fondamentale
n'est même pas les pour un final et que
j'ai des fans
[Musique]
le alors imaginez-vous et les emplettes
sans point final
c'est pour façon parce que à mon avis il
veut donner justement cette musique et
en vidéo grâce à des licences
en contrepartie le deuxième chapitre il
parle des faits les actions ashley est
compris et commence bien dans mon
française imeda si vous coupez aime être
d'accord avec moi quand j'utilise le
temps de mal en parfait j'ai parlé des
actions qui ont commencé pour passer
elles ont eu une journée
metz
elles ont fini mais de toute façon cette
asu là c'est pas énorme
pourtant je chantais c'est pas vrai je
suivais les clercs et caetera
et dans le deuxième choc et que j'ai les
idées plutôt le passé l'accent commence
et termine l'année cela fait plus de 30
bon j'ai mis 10
c en trois pages toute cette foule et je
vais travailler avec nous vous pouvez
accompagner avec moi
quand on sait quand on écrit des
représentations j'ai vu que j'ai fait à
peine si j'ai pensé quoi ça je ne parle
même pas c'est particulier en compte
celle ci avait plombé l'ambiance est
super motivé
je pense pas car de sable
mélangé les terrains
mais cette façon je n'aurais jamais
c'est
parce que
j'ai besoin de souffler
ils le crient au génie civil ou non
seulement ils nous ont reconnus comme
crise et les annonces à que kouakou jean
rous et souvent à la normale on gagne
tous les jours avant toute chose il
remis annuellement
3 2 alors ce qu'il
faut c'est un coup de
[Musique]
fil
des mois
les réunions par hamid al sheikh usmani
il
ne s'est pas
réveillé
[Musique]
jimmy rollins a figé la culture du soin
mutuel et j'entends bien que cela va
faire que le sort ses deux
fils
et je ne
sais pas si l'économie nationale il faut
il faut année nous
fêtons convient de rappeler petit jeune
premier
yonekawa
j'ai eu des coups tout elle provient
opportunément
[Musique]
masoni
je veux que les sites sûrs santé et
beaucoup
de professions de brotherhood calme pour
l'embellissement sont sauvés du film
parce que tu ne sais pas trop ce qui
nous énerve aux millions d'autres je
sors de mon fait son plein de mousse
fois décroché ce brave
nous n'allons pas les choses ça car ce
n'est pas toujours le cas du big band
qui
il fait goûter qui a trait à la douane
française
sans oublier d'insister l'imminente est
contre moi pour son équipe
[Musique]
j'ai fait un geste mais qu'est-ce qu'on
ne dépassera pas les contrats de carouge
je suis fatigué kim à ce niveau alors ça
c'est un exemple de cette mélodie encore
en sait lire et on n'avance pas et
il est alors intéressant
et pas sous ma direction vous prend dans
les voitures ne transforme en elles
beaucoup quel présent
mais chacun va continuellement ses
personnels alors sa lisibilité c'est
qu'elle ne fait
il va falloir arracher les l'ignorance
et des changements
changement parfois c'est un petit
changement en fait changer le titre
est-il
oui
et d'arrêter leur profil elle ne me
posais milite de vannes forme d'avancé
ça serait trop binaire elle va élargir
nos horizons
et ça c'est de pouvoir
de la formation des séries de
transformer un peu et on vivre
tous font déjà 160
lits alors c'est une question à vos
canines changer votre vie et beaucoup
aimer dieu aucun attaquant mais j'en
suis sûr qu'il intitule dans un moment
dans votre en livre une à fouetter
motion j'ai
alors merci
[Applaudissements]